nada fx y que se expresa como gx elevado
al cuadrado la gráfica de g y su recta
tangente en x igual a 4 se muestran a
continuación cuál es el valor de f prima
en 4 es decir la derivada de f evaluada
en 4 y aquí tenemos justamente la
gráfica de nuestra función g que de
hecho parece como una parábola y nos dan
la recta tangente justamente en el punto
donde estamos evaluando la función en 4
es decir en el 4,3 y 3 es cuánto vale la
función g en 4 muy bien entonces
utilizando esto podemos resolver este
problema como lo vamos a hacer
tenemos que fx fx es igual
vamos a ponerlo con otro color es igual
a gd x esto elevado al cuadrado entonces
si nosotros queremos saber quién es la
derivada de f pues tenemos que derivar
de ambos lados con respecto a x entonces
derivamos respecto de x f de x y nos
debe dar lo mismo que la derivada de con
respecto de x d g de x al cuadrado muy
bien entonces quien es la derivada
respecto de x de fx pues eso es
simplemente f prima de xy que es justo
lo que queremos encontrar aunque lo
queremos evaluado en 4 ahora bien del
lado derecho
esto será igual a la derivada de gx al
cuadrado pero nosotros sabemos que si
derivamos por ejemplo x cuadrada su
derivada es 2x pero aquí hay que
utilizar la regla de la cadena muy bien
entonces esto simplemente nos quedará
como si deriva como si derivar amos
equis cuadrada que es 2x pero en este
caso sería
gdx y luego por regla de la cadena
multiplicamos por la derivada de lo que
está aquí que es la derivada de g muy
bien entonces ya tenemos todo lo
necesario para poder resolver nuestro
problema porque queremos nosotros f
prima en 4
efe prima en 4 cuánto es esto será igual
a 2 veces he evaluado en 4 por la
derivada evaluada en 4 muy bien pero
nosotros sabemos muy bien quién es g de
4 quien es g de 4 pues nos vamos al
punto 4 y la función está evaluada bueno
al evaluar la función nos da 3 esto de
aquí es 3 ahora cuánto vale la derivada
en 4 pues es simplemente la pendiente de
la recta tangente y que aquí nos la
están dando entonces tenemos que ver
cuánto es la pendiente si nos damos
cuenta y avanzamos 2 en esta dirección
vamos a tener que bajar 4 entonces aquí
tenemos más 2
pero bajamos 4 y recordemos que la
pendiente la pendiente es justamente lo
que es lo que nos elevamos entre lo que
avanzamos y lo que nos elevamos en
realidad es es decreciente verdad de
hecho tenemos un de bueno bajamos 4
unidades y avanzamos 2 así que nuestra
pendiente es menos 2 está pendiente es
menos 2 y por lo tanto que prima de 4 es
menos 2 así que en realidad esto
simplemente se traduce a 2 x 3 que son 6
y multiplicamos por menos 26 x menos 2
son menos 12 y ahí tienen el resultado